[Music]
hi tony it's so great to have you here
thank you for being with us today
um you are one of the most celebrated
and most decorated business leaders in
africa and i would posit the world so
it's truly an honor to be able to host
you at stanford this afternoon thank you
very much we watched a video earlier um
where we learned a little bit about the
foundation which we'll speak about
towards the later half of the interview
but we saw there that you're such a
supporter and such an advocate of
entrepreneurship which isn't really a
surprise because your parents were
entrepreneurs i'm curious to know how
seeing them build businesses at a young
age
influenced you and impacted your journey
so i'm pleased and honored to be with
you all today
stanford
great university
and
a team
from this great university if you study
10 tonya melo foundation
before the pandemic i think
and i was quite
impressed
they were on time
it's part of this
this part of the
chaotic traffic situation
in lagos
and the research work
also very very
impressive
so for me coming back here
such as oh no
have a great impression of your school
entrepreneurship is
is
in my dna
i preach entrepreneurship
i
encourage entrepreneurship
i also try
to catalyze more entrepreneurs in africa
because in my own life journey
i've come to appreciate the significance
and importance of entrepreneurship
in transforming families
in transforming self
in transforming communities
in transforming communities
in transforming countries societies and
humanity entirely
and when we find that determining the
foundation
it was driven
but they need
an urgency
to help catalyze development
in africa at a skilled
sustainable
realizing further that entrepreneurship
is the way to that
i was
privileged
lucky
blessed
to have been mentored
in this journey of entrepreneurship
first by my parents
especially my mom who was an
entrepreneur
small skill
but
the lessons i imbibed
watching her
supporting her
continue to help me to date
and it's also critical
in the message
and advice i give to young entrepreneurs
i learned
from her about hard work
she was
extremely extremely hard working at the
time
to date she just turned 94 and she's
still very hard on me
she will cook for me and i
driver to come apologize pick food
and i'm like mom
i have so many people to cook for me but
that spirit
in her
remains ever so strong
she was disciplined
and i've come to realize that this
journey of entrepreneurship
they said before not just
entrepreneurship everything in life
discipline is critical for success
she was extremely tenacious
and i've come to see
and i preached too
that the journey entrepreneurship
is not a linear journey
it's up and down
but if you're tenacious if you are
resilient
you cross the finishing line
so those are part of
the early learnings from
my parents my mom my dad
long ago told us
and the reason is see my brain today
that if you earn
a dollar
and you're unable to save
if you earn a billion dollars you will
not save anything
so that for me is the first lesson in
capital formation
capital formation starts from savings
if you do not save
you don't have money to invest
if you don't invest you remain where you
are
and so these lessons have helped me in
this journey of entrepreneurship
so let's fast forward a few years you
graduate from university with a
bachelor's and a master's degree in
economics you then proceed to become one
of the youngest bank branch managers in
nigeria typically a job reserve for
people who are in their 50s or 60s you
become the managing director of one of
the most one of the biggest banks in
nigeria and then 2005 comes around and
you are being asked to help lead what
becomes like the biggest merger in
nigeria's corporate history
what were some of the challenges that
you faced during that time and which
leadership principles did you stay
rooted in as you were guiding this
process
at the time
[Music]
quite a lot of challenges
but
just to contextualize to understand it
we took over a distressed bank called
standard trust bank in 1997
and in 2005
we met standard trust bank a united ban
for africa
but before the major there was an
acquisition standard was acquiring
significant interest in united north
africa that would match
and i imagine the ceo so first
you saw united above africa as almost 70
years old as an institution
and uh
kicked and set ways of doing things
then digital adoption was not so strong
and so
at times it took people months to read
males in this
and
[Music]
you
in terms of service delivery those days
the old generation banks were not so
strong on service delivery
and we were coming from
a bank that was so strong savvy delivery
and technology young people etc
so a bank was size of
less than 1 800 people
and the united bank of africa had about
12 000 staff
this 1800
younger
technologically advanced
and this other
older
and
very big bank so it's not easy
integrating because as you see corporate
majors
the legal combination is not the issue
the difficult part is the people
integration
the cultural integration
that is the top part
and so
and if you can see from history most
corporate institutions
it takes so many years to integrate
people and culture
and if you do not integrate people and
culture properly you lose the major
value levers
and so we were mindful of this i wanted
to make sure we were able to merge
integrate and this is a financial
institution that was like
you match the one customers don't care
whether they want to be served same
institution they move down
there's a tough
integrating our people imagine our
people emerging cultures
old cultural state
setting their ways and a vibrant younger
culture
but therein lies the
interesting aspect of the combination of
the job i say to people my
elder brother who is seven years older
than me
he doesn't have grey hair
i have gray my gray hairs are there for
the company measure
because
making it work
serving your customers
making sure that everyone in the of the
institution
which was a were 428 branches at the
time
that it was same level of service across
both customers of standard transplant
that were used to a certain level of
safety delivery
you will not want them to come to the
new institution and have a drop so we
just have to
make sure that
service will put our customers and
that's why today united north africa
which interestingly
has grown
from a one
country bank
to a bank that oppressed in 20 african
countries
with presence also in
paris london recently dubai
and the only african bank that are
placed in u.s with it as a deposit
taking administration
he started small
he's gone that big
and
that experience during the measure
continue to guide what we do especially
how we prioritize our customers
and how to practise our people so i
would say the biggest lesson from that
combination
was
making
our people integrate now people and
culture
was realizing that
especially in the service
sector
where you sell
intangible so to speak
it is a very important that your core
army your workforce that they are fully
aligned totally integrated
and positively mobilized and motivated
if you like this you can make progress
and
those lessons from the early days
you know
resilience
hard work discipline staying focused
prioritizing people
have all helped
us in creating today's united bank for
africa
and as you mentioned you all were able
to do that very successfully you
expanded from being a single country
bank to one that operates in more than
20 countries in africa and then has an
impact and influence and reach in other
countries as well
many of us are interested in working in
emerging markets or are building
developing products or services for
emerging markets or one emerging market
to begin with i'm curious to know how do
you evaluate
which markets to enter when you're
expanding united bank of africa and um
and when do you determine how do you
determine what's the right when's the
right time to do so
so first is
most times people see
the empty part of a glass
at times we see also the full part of
the glass
you would always have difficulties and
challenges in
every almost every sector especially
countries you want to go into
so when we decided to expand into africa
the story was first
we thought that um we had a my side out
of
seven customers because that's what
banking is about banks is about uh
saving your customers it's all about
customers customers customers
and realizing that to serve your
customers you must have a mobilized
workforce that's aligned with those
mission and vision that you see for the
for the group
so we felt looking at the afghan
landscape
that we had opportunities we thought
nigeria was the remains the largest
economy in africa
and we thought that
the level of banking or service
service support
was very high and i should leverage this
and spread across the continent
and we had to decide which country
should we go to how do we decide the
country microeconomic stability policies
etc
foreign exchange policies you know ease
of doing business and countries taxation
policies and countries
and the demographic of country because
we were quite upset that would so like
to support small ambient scale
enterprises you know that is the bedrock
of united but for africa
and uh so based on that
we came up with 30 countries
that met the internal criteria we
settled
according the the uv developer called
ibia redbook how wanted to explain
africa
issue to consider etc
but in all of those issues
the ease of doing business in countries
was very critical
we
the population was also important the
gdp of countries income per capita was
important ease of finding the right
human capital to work with because again
you see people business so that was very
important to us
and we came up with all of this we now
teared it we have what we call it what
we develop what called the third tier
strategic intent
tier one was wanted to be
strong in nigeria tier two
be a leading fan african bank and tier
three
being a global having present global
financial centers which is why we talk
about london paris new york dubai it's
all part of our three-tier strategic
intent
the second one therefore orchestrating
our expansion in africa
and on that was
what strategy do we do a county strategy
or not you know pass through
or have presence in countries and we
decided that we need to have presence in
countries
and next was okay how do the countries
let's cheer the countries again we use
gdpr some of the entire countries and we
say rolling that greenfield broadfield
acquisition measures how do you want to
grow
we decided that
we do a combination of both so in the
countries we went to some countries were
acquired banks some were merged and some
we started
greenfield and the journey so far so
good today
united banff africa sells
over 35 million customers in africa
and still growing
we're helping
to simplify
payments on the continent
while helping to orchestrate trade
transactions intra africa trade
transactions
prior to this time africa did not trade
with
and amongst itself
or we we believe the reason africa
didn't do this is on because payment
issues
because of uh even infrastructure even
transportation infrastructure
and also
making sure we support our capacity
small mineral scale
to grow so uba has has done quite a bit
in this space and most importantly
financial inclusion
trying to make sure
that
everyone
a continent with about 1 billion people
the banking population is not so high
so to us it's not just about banking
ourself offering banking services
it's about what we call democratization
of access to financial services
it's about financial inclusion so i'm
making sure that almost everyone
in markets will operate have access to
banking facilities
and that's a banking services and that's
in some countries
quite beheaded a pioneered
opening of bank account zero balances
because what's important to us is to be
able to attract
people we believe that africa will have
informal economy that is very large
and all of us should be involved in
trying to
formalize the formal economy and this is
one of the ways we're doing so through
our banking service in other areas of
our operation and as a group
we're trying to try to do the same thing
what we do at the tunnel melu foundation
is all again about helping to develop
the continent financial empowerment
taking opportunities to people
irrespective of your you resolve your
level in the society
where yourself where you live whether in
the urban or rural areas so those are
things
we need to keep doing to create a more
inclusive society especially in africa
you
you alluded to this a little bit earlier
there's a lot of innovation happening in
the financial services industry a lot of
tech disruptors and all
many of which are working towards that
goal of democratizing access to
financial services
what like from your position as ceo and
now chairman of united bank of africa
what do you how do you see the company
collaborating or or even competing with
some of these disruptors particularly
thinking about new technologies like
cryptocurrencies peer-to-peer payments
et cetera
advice is uh
i
was ceo of ubn the chief executive of
united south africa
about 12 years ago
so today
i don't see myself as a banker person
i'm an investor that plays
invest in banking
in
helping to improve access to electricity
on the continent in a critical resource
deficit on the continent that's
important to preach if almost
your jaffra leapfrog and moved
the continent to where she being
with investors in healthcare sector
who have realized that
indeed health is worth
if the pandemic thought was one thing
it is about prioritizing health and
realizing that what the war
couldn't do health or lack of it can do
it who would have thought that the
entire world would go into a lockdown
mode i did i know i thought that could
happen in my lifetime so my investment
in that sector we're investing in energy
you know the
the full energy change because again for
a continent like africa's critical force
for for growth so
for us or for me at this point i'm not
so much of a bank however
uh as a group we realize the importance
of technology
that you know the
these two disruptions that we see in the
world israel
and in africa in particular thanks to
the the population of our continent we
know that
we have to catch up if we don't catch up
we're going to left behind and for
businesses and business we're associated
with like united above africa and other
businesses
digital
adoption is critical
for service delivery for everything that
we do so in the payment space
we lead in the payment space through
digitization through adoption
partnership with fintechs and all kinds
just to make sure that we're able to
serve our customers
today's customers
they don't need
a bank they don't need a facilitator for
payments you know they need a fighter
that follow their lifestyle
so and banking is changing it's changing
from the way we used to know banking so
many years ago today you can sit in your
heart fat i tell you
a united bank of africa two days later
we have 35 million customers
a few years ago no 2005 when we did the
major between standard trust my united
north africa
all of 2004
uba celebrated was the first bank in
nigeria to have 32 atms 32 8 years in
all of
marketing tool that we have 32 atms
and then the first bike also to pay out
one billion
a local currency billionaire in cash
then let's just say hundred dollars only
an hour per dollar in cash
today
and then
then
97 percent of our
customer transactions are called in the
banking hall
today
uba opens about 500 000 accounts every
month
and these accounts these accounts
95 percent are opened
online
not in the banking hall
number two
transaction count we have
over 98 percent of our customer
transaction now occurring
online
not in banking hall
again
in terms of atms uva loan just uv alone
has close of four thousand atms in
nigeria all from studies
all from the picture
and of course posses uncountable there
are no ps before so things have changed
and by the way it will change further
they totally i mean technology is
disrupting a lot of things not just in
the u.s not in the west but everywhere
everywhere evil healthcare in our hair
care sector
today
healthcare can be delivered
digitally online
and everything so we we we live in a
very
new world and every one of us
is
adopting and adapting faster to the new
world i will be living
you mentioned energy a little earlier
which makes me nervous because it seems
as though you're reading my mind because
that's where i want to go next
um last year the africa energy chamber
recognized you as one of the 25 most
influential individuals in shaping
africa's energy sector i'm curious to
know especially knowing that stanford
sustainability and energy and renewable
energy and energy more broadly is a
really important subject that gets
studied here and talked about a lot
what are the most pressing issues and
solutions being discussed right now has
released energy in africa and also i
would love to know a little bit more
about the work that you're doing i think
i believe through transcore to address
this
so
access to electricity is extremely poor
in africa
less than 35 percent of our people
have access to reliable
electricity on the continent
this is a continent of young people
over 700 million people are young
on the continent under the age of 30
and yet access to electricity is almost
impossible
these young ones are in a very
competitive world
they are going to compete with children
who are used
to 24 7 uninterrupted electricity supply
so the world we see ahead is actually
frightening because
the divide we want to breach
is not the case happening in the digital
space it's not happening because of
access lack of access to reliable sort
of energy on the continent
and
from the work we do at the toniel melu
foundation
from our close interaction with young
africans
male females
we
know we can tell we see we hear listen
to them
that access to electricity is a major
hindrance
constraint
on their ability to succeed
this is why most i'm sure you stand for
you must have seen this
in your business
research
studies
the most small and middle school
enterprise on the content die
they don't succeed
and single most important factor for
this little poor access to electricity
so to us as a group
we believe in the concept and philosophy
of african capitalism
which is
a call on the private sector to place a
role in developing a continent
it's a realization that the private
sector has a role to play in developing
the continent
and in
practicalizing this and not just
speaking to it
we decided that the power sector was
critical for us to invest in
and so we mobilize resources and invest
in this space
today we have capacity to generate about
2000 megahertz of electricity
but we have some other hindrances like
gas supply and
grid
connectivity
so we're able to generate about 700
megahertz out of the capacity of 2000
but
we're happy
that we're
playing a key role
in this area
but
my message always has been to invest us
we've started being on this trip we
started from washington we've been to
new york contracted a lot to invest in
new york
when
l.a we attended the making institute
which had a garden of global asset
managers and foreigners our message my
message has been consistent
we have opportunities in africa there's
huge opportunity in africa a huge
population
our income per capita has improved is
improving
and
we lack access to electricity on the
continent
so as the world mobilizes
towards a more inclusive society
i the world mobilize it through
to
a more prosperous world
i
always like to remind people
that i cannot have that prosperity
across the world
it will not deal with the issue of
access to electricity on the african
continent
the reason we have youth unemployment in
africa is attributable to this
the reason we have youth restiveness in
africa is attributed to this
the reason some embrace extremism is
attributable to this in fact
government's ability to cover fight
extremism is also limited by this
so at times you see communities and
large
spaces
that do not feel any impact of
government or society because not
electricity
so it's a major for me it's not just an
investment you know a commercial
investment
is um
it's what we should be doing in the 21st
century to help improve access to
electricity
and
yeah i can never shout or say enough and
i want to have more people
in this in this crusade that all of us
those who have capital
should look
at investing in africa there are
opportunities there
and those who have voices
let's keep shouting to attract attention
or those who have deep focus so that
collectively all of us can make a
difference
in the africa
i want to stay a little bit i want to
spend some time on what you mentioned
earlier afrocapitalism
which you are known across nigeria and
other countries as well i've been a
strong proponent of and you've detailed
here
i'm curious to know why you believe that
africa needs to take a unique approach
to capitalism
well it's not
a unique approach to capitalism
a per se is for me
a realization okay so
at times
you
there's this
entitlement mentality that people have
okay
we should be helped we should be
supported we should be developed
but for christ's sake
you know i mean it can be like that
forever
we need to have ourselves too
so it's a realization that come
the private sector
has also grown is growing
we need government to prioritize the
only government to create the right
environment for private sector to keep
doing well
but the privacy also must
be
sensible and
reasonable
and conscientious in how we do things
okay
we we should invest in a manner
that helps to catalyze prosperity we
should invest in a manager helps
to to create social equity social work
we should invest in a manner that helps
to create inclusiveness
so this is not just about a new form of
capitalism or the other it's more about
how the fact that the privacy should
play
a role in helping to develop the corner
let's stop blaming others for our words
let's stop blaming others for everything
let's lead and hopefully they follow and
i've seen it happen you know some of the
investments we have made
we did not invest all the capital
ourselves
we reach out
and we see that the world we live in is
becoming highly interdependent
and people also begin to listen
especially we show good example okay
so it's said call all of us privacy that
we're in africa outside the world that
will have a role to play
in advanced society again the meeting i
attended in early
it all had different names today
you know
patient capital
impact investing
shared prosperity
mutual destinies we just need to invest
in a manner that's not just about
profits
for the investors
we should invest in a manner that
creates
mutual benefits for everyone but
investors
for communities where you do business in
for society at large
the fact that we do what we do at the
attorney mili foundation committing 100
million u.s dollars to supporting
nigeria afghan entrepreneurs
it's not because we have so much money
but we also know that
some of the basic needs
we want to have are provided
so
it's not about what we have in the bank
account
said about
that in that in the bag how can we take
a part of it and share
but for me not even sharing a manner
that creates a dependency perpetual
dependency no
in a manner that makes you
stand on your own it makes you
self-reliant and so when we
say we'll give non-refund they will see
capital of five thousand dollars
and when we do so and to date over
sixteen thousand africans have benefited
from that program
it is not to encourage laziness no
but we know when
san francisco where in tech
environment
we know some started with less than five
thousand dollars but today they've grown
big so we just want to give young
africans
access
opportunity
opportunity to prove their concept
and then let others see them as good and
commonly best in them so we need all the
privacy of plain euro we need everyone
we need privacy all looking at critical
sectors today we talked i just talked
about electricity
instead of people keeping their moneys
and bank accounts abroad why did you
bring your money to invest in the let's
set on the continent you make more money
but
you also impact
society in a more positive way
that is
the entire essence of it is so
we we need more
private sector leaders showing the way
but we need also our public sector
leaders creating the right environment
that will enable the privacy to do and
we need friends of africa development
partners also begin to look at how
how they intervene how they engage and
how they give in 21st century with the
aim
to create self-reliance and independence
rather than
perpetuating
the syndrome of dependency
now tony typically when people retire
from
very high stress jobs such as being the
ceo
one of the largest banks in africa they
take a vacation
you instead decided to found a company
air is holding and also the foundation
that you've alluded to
i'm curious this was back this was a few
years ago i'm curious about what you saw
happening like in nigeria or
beyond that at that time that drove that
was the impetus for you to develop this
foundation
we did two things
when i retired in 2010
12 years ago
we decided to create
a family office
which was to some extent novel in our
part of the world
and we said the family office
will be quite catholic
in the kind of investment that we make
hence this philosophy of african
capitalism so as audience
is
epitome and
this home of our
overall group a lot in the philosophy of
african policy
and decided the sectors are considered
very important that we have to move the
nato
power
when nigeria and africa is endowed with
a lot of resources
yet we do not have
the ability to process all of this and
convert them to the state
that they can become valuable to our
people so we said energy
from an integrated point of view and
across the value chains
we looked at healthcare sector
and we said health is important that we
need to invest in the healthcare sector
so these were the key of course real
estate on patent africa and hospitality
hospitality if you want to grow a
country an economy transportation
and
hospitality
critical for for this so those are the
things we decided to
to do at the time the motivation was
to help
drive our philosophy of capitalism
further
but equally important to help manage the
investments
and wanted to pressure as audience as
they go to investment partners on the
continent
i wanted to help to attract investment
to the continent
and so far
so good on that and the other the other
thing we did the second thing was the
foundation
i thought that um
my story has been one of um
this element of luck in my story
this element of being at the right place
at the right time
and i i wasn't the most intelligent in
my class you know and also
i wasn't the most hardworking you know
of my
certain people i knew
and therefore there must be luck in it
that i'm who i am what i became
and i thought
you know i'd risen very rapidly don't
quite do a lot
and i thought it was time to commit
this second phase of my life
to helping to impart humanity to helping
to to
to democratize that lock that i had
growing up
to help
expand access to opportunities
to help
people
i mean i
spoke about parents i said i have to
remember small-scale entrepreneur but
not the kind of big
see
and so i was not like a
son
of any known
no
known families so to speak just regular
family person and so
you know
and i've been inspired by what i see
around the world you know look at
steve job for instance you know and his
background
and i asked myself see job where in
africa if i was an african in nigeria
would they have been able to succeed
at the scale i'm magnitude i succeeded i
mean long after his death
you know a company is funded first to
cross 1 trillion a market cap
and john recently you know
so it's all of these that drove me to
say no
it to be
an unfortunate i don't know what i would
say to god
if i do not create or have to create
maternity eliminates
on the continent of afghanistan
and that was what drove
drove
my wife and i at the time
to decide that
we should commit 100 million uh dollars
to helping
to identify
support
and empower
the negation of afghan leaders
and to do it
the scale and magnitude
that's never been done before
given that we do business in many
african countries we decided to know
that we have a nigerian
issue about africa
given that we know that poverty and usa
threat to all of us everywhere would
serve to make sure that it's broader and
so that
is why
we started the attorney el melo
foundation so the motivation for
starting the tony almeida foundation
is to help democratize lock
create access to people
whether or not you are a big man child
or a permanent
you have ideas
you're enthusiastic you're committed
ambitious
applied and
the sector agnostic
will give you opportunity and so when i
look back today
i see that as a major
a major achievement what to have done
the happiness i see on the faces of
these are young africans
keeps me going
so my final question for you
you seem to be a nation and of yourself
through the foundation you've worked
with local governments international
governing bodies
to help move capital where it's most
needed and so i'm sure you've heard it
asked many times before nigeria is now
in its election season
i will join the chorus why aren't you
running for president
[Laughter]
i didn't see that coming where's your
assassin
i think first is
when i look around
i know
the potential that we have as a
continent
and as a people
i see opportunities
i know that
life can be a lot better
for people
and oftentimes you feel the urge
to
to
to show interest in how we're governed
and how things happen
but i soon also realized that
because
i've never been selfish
because i've never been self-centered
because never been
to me that must be turning
i said to myself
if there are other good people capable
people
who are in the race who are showing
interest
why don't you
support them
and share with them
what you think should be the right thing
in terms of leadership in terms of
governance in the 21st century africa
where people have suffered and continued
to suffer so much
you know
i realized also that
all of us cannot be in the political
space
by nowhere that
evil
success or tries in the world when good
people keep quiet
so i said to myself
just the way i'm committed to
entrepreneurship do i'm committed to
helping to empower young africans
we should
support emergence
and orchestration
of good governance
across the continent
because i think that is what has held us
done
as africans
so for me you know japan nigeria is
about many
countries many countries on the
continent
so
i am interested in good confidence
and i know that what we preach and
advocacy and everything we do trying to
encourage young people
will not succeed in the political space
our leadership is not good
so mine is for to continue to encourage
the evolution
of
the political process
that we want
throughout good leadership
and two
ensure that our leaders stay accountable
that
process
is not there yet
but we
are working together and i against one
area
when i was in washington i said to
paul kulaship here too that it should be
a concerted effort you should encourage
people on the continent
to do what is right
even as we also from the continent
continue to speak and have
on good governance and accountability
thank you so much tony that was amazing
and typically we like to close with a
lightning round of questions so i have
four for you and i'm going to say them
and you have to answer as quickly as
possible hence the lightning part okay
um so outside of aside from palo alto
california what's your favorite place to
visit
i think that's okay what's your favorite
place to travel to oh outside
i just came from l.a los angeles i love
los angeles more than san francisco no
no you didn't say mother he said he's
that assigned from he said outside
this
mother um now with nigeria out of the
world cup who are you rooting for
wow
even my my boys who were they were like
crying when they dropped i think i think
nigeria's
[Laughter]
um what is your favorite whisk kid song
hit song which what's your favorite
whiz kid
whiskey song
[Laughter]
you don't know that i don't know it can
you do something
can you tell us who has the iphone yet
you have to play
um and last question what are you most
grateful for
oh
i'm grateful to god for my wife and
family and children
i think
you know
you can't do well in life if you don't
have
a home that's at peace
i do have a very peaceful home and my
children are reinforcing too
so i'm grateful to god for that thank
you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
you